Jason uh can take us through the first
play what happened with your ankle and
how did that impact you for the rest of
the game
I saw the video and I saw it after the
game that uh and I came down
you know my ankle uh
and it's tough because
it you know kind of impacted me the rest
of the night
swelled up and it was just frustrating
that I was kind of like a shell of
myself it's tough to move
it was just frustrating especially you
know she happened on the first play
and
what happened with the team effort it
seemed like you guys couldn't get shots
down they did you guys got discouraged
what what happened out there tonight as
a whole
yeah I think uh just the nice shooting
the ball well
uh had an effect on us throughout the
game and it just kind of snowballed
Jason with the you know sprained ankle
game seven no margin for error is is
there a tendency to kind of look back at
maybe
the game two where you guys had an
opportunity to win and maybe maybe
missed opportunities in the past that
wouldn't have put you in a position like
this
uh I mean I don't
you can't go through life talking about
what you could have you should have done
right you know happens and
the past is the past and we felt like
hell to get myself you know a chance
today
uh
you know just not the outcome that we
anticipated